ممثله امريكيه والدتها سوداء ووالدها ابيض
هي غائبه عن الصوره لكنها حاضره في قلب
القصه والدها هو توماس دابليو ماركل الحظ
على جائزه ايمي في فئه افضل مدير فني وفتح
لها باب الدخول لعالم الفن حصلت على شهاده
الدراسات المتطوره في المسرح قبل ان تنتهي
من درجه البكالوريوس في المسرح الدولي في
عام 2011 جسده ماركه شخصيه ريتشل في مسلسل
سوس حتى انا اشتهرت بهذا الاسم هي الزوجه
السابقه للممثل والمنتج تريفر انجلسي لكن
هو ما انفصل بعد علاقه وزواج نحو ثمان
سنوات التقت ميغان بهاري في حفله عشاء
بحكمه اهتمامها بالاعمال الخيريه لكن هاري
كشف سابقا في احد لقاءاته عن فتاه احلامه
وقال انها ماركل فتاه من اصول الافريقيه
اقتحمت الاسره الملكه كانت هذه هي كلمات
استخدامات صحف بريطانيه في تقاريرها لوصف
عام 2018
ومنذ ارتباطهما وعدسات ووسائل الاعلام حول
العالم تلاحقهما والسبب بحسبهاري في لقاء
الاخير لانها امريكيه وممثله ومطلقه
وسوداء وثنا القات العرق بدات خلافتهما
مبكرا مع التقاليد والعادات الملكيه فكسرت
القواعد باطلالتها البسيطه ببطال الجنس
والقميص الابيض في ظهورها بعد الزواج
وكذلك العوده لاستخدام وسائل التواصل